là on a un bel individu c'est une espèce
de verre plat invasif qui représente une
menace potentiellement pour nos ver de
terre français car il est carnivore
c'est un vrai petit monstre à la base ce
verre carnivore il vit en Amérique du
Sud pourtant depuis plusieurs années on
le retrouve sous nos pieds ici en France
et comme plusieurs espèce introduite il
fait planer une menace on sait qu'ils
sont capables d'emprunter les galeries
de verre de terre donc il peuvent les
suivre en fait dans les trous tu vois le
ver de terre là qui se débattre ou pas
mon collègue Floriant est allé à la
rencontre d'une scientifique qui lui a
présenté cet animal à étonnant et un peu
flippant il a notamment appris qu'il
digère des proies hors de son corps et
qu'il pourrait même se multiplier en se
clonant pour cet épisode de la grande
explication on s'est demandé pourquoi
l'arrivée de ce verre inquiète des
scientifiques de quoi est-il capable on
vous
explique du coup quand ça les mange en
fait ça va sortir son pharinx c'est
comme si vous pouviez sortir l'intérieur
de votre gorge le mettre sur votre
aliment et juste l'aspirer comme ça
c'est clairement des alien cette espèce
de verre plat elle est originaire
d'Amérique du Sud donc ces ver ils sont
introduits via le commerce de plant en
poau c'est pour ça que principalement on
les retrouveent dans les jardins parce
que les personnes vont acheter des
plantes exotiques les mettent dans leur
jardin et potentiellement le coloniser
avec les ver plat qui sont présents dans
les racines ou dans la terre qui est
autour de la plante c'est sa tête après
c'est pas une tête comme on imagine nous
parce que par exemple ses yeux ils sont
sur tout le long de son corps il en a
des milliers on a en fait un particulier
qui récupère les ver plats tous les
jours dans son jardin
donc il y en a un là déjà et il y en a
là il y en a ici c'est une espèce qui
est particulièrement abondante dans les
jardins envahis on peut en trouver des
millions et notamment ce jardin en
particulier il a trouvé 1500 Obama
nungara en un mois dans son jardin on en
a des un peu plus clair que ça peut
avoir un impact très fort parce que
c'est pas du tout des espèces qui sont
censé être là à la base et elles sont ni
reconnues par les proies parce que Ben
une chèvre qui a jamais vu un loup c'est
pas que c'est un loup et pareil pour les
prédateurs d'invertébré a priori eux ils
sont pas mangés par d'autres espèces en
tout cas en France parce que les oiseaux
ils vont pas se dire HM c'est un repas
donc alors là on a du coup plusieurs
élevages donc en haut on va voir les
Obama euh au milieu les manipes donc les
expériences qui sont en cours en bas les
proies là on revient d'une session de
terrain c'est pour ça qu'on en a autant
je vais mettre des gant pardon hop
certaines espèces de verre plat sont
toxiques on sait pas si le eux le sont
mais dans le doute on prend nos
précautions
du coup je prends toutes les boîtes de
l'expérience en cours qu'on va contrôler
aujourd'hui parce que du coup j'ai six
boîtes dans chaque boîte on a du coup un
verre plat et trois de ces proies donc
là l'idée c'est qu'en fait on va ouvrir
la boîte et regarder ce qui a été mangé
donc là ce que vous voyez ici je dois
tourner c'est un cadavre de nimas donc
elle elle s'est fait se fait manger
c'est un peu dégueu mais c'est comme ça
c'est la nature donc là on a une imasse
mangé et du coup donc ils adorent he se
mettre sous les carreaux de céramique
les Obama ningara donc là on va vraiment
chercher soigneusement euh si les autres
tris sont visibles et là juste à côté
vous pouvez voir le l'Obama qui se cache
le truc marron la tête est là et donc là
on a notre dernier survivant de ce
colanta des vers de terre c'est ce petit
escargot c'est pour ça que là on fait
ses tests he avec ces différentes espèce
c'est pour savoir s'ils vont manger une
espèce plus qu'une autre s'ils mangent
tout de manière à peu près équivalente
bon ça va avoir un impact sur
l'abondance mais l'écosystème peut
continuer à évoluer dans le sens on va
dire classique il se
barre voyez il est vraiment plein par
rapport au verre de terre qui est à côté
ça c'est le même que tout à l'heure oh
dis-moi que tu as pas mangé l'autre là
espèce de goinfre
[Musique]
VDT tout à l'heure c'était une limass un
escargot et un verre de terre et là on a
mis un on a fait des boîtes où on a mis
trois espèces de verre de terre dans le
sol sol en fait on va avoir les verrs de
terre qui sont en surface qui eux vont
plutôt dégrader de la matière organique
assez fraîche donc des choses qui sont
plutôt des gros morceaux on va dire des
des feuilles mortes mais encore assez
fraîches les verres de terre qui vont
être plutôt intermédiaires qui en fait
eux vont faire l'ascenseur entre les
profondeurs et le haut et donc eu ils
sont hyper hyper importants pour déjà
augmenter la porosité du sol donc
permettre à l'eau de rentrer dans le sol
euh donc il sont de plutôt de plus
grande taille et on a des vers de terre
comme ceux-là hein qui eux vont être en
profondeur et qui vont vraiment manger
quasiment que de la terre si on a un
déséquilibre entre un de ces groupes et
ben on va se retrouver avec un un souci
parce que si la matière organique n'est
pas dégradée par ce du dessus il y a un
problème si la matière organique qui est
dégradée par ce du dessus n'est pas
apportée par les intermédiaires on a un
d'autres problèm et du coup eux vont
mourir et donc après ça peut
potentiellement déséquilibrer
l'écosystème donc là il en a mangé un
autre he d'ailleurs c'est une manim qui
dure sur plusieurs semaines
euh le sol c'est vraiment le support de
notre alimentation notre alimentation et
l'alimentation de tous les êtres vivants
de petits scarabé au ser donc si les
vers de terre viennent à disparaître et
ben on a une perte complètement les
plantes peuvent plus obtenir leurs
minéraux dans le sol la matière
organique don elles ont besoin pour
grandir et cetera c'est vraiment le une
réaction enchaîne sur l'ensemble de
l'écosystème là je peux vous montrer du
coup des cocons et des juvéniles
d'obaman ingara qu'on a qu'on a là au
labo et
[Musique]
normalement
al donc là vous voyez il y a un individu
quand même qui nous a fait 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
H8 cocons en 2 semaines hein c'est une
espèce qui peut voilà se se répendre
rapidement parce que dans chaque cocon
on a 10 juvéniles euh donc ils vont pas
tous atteindre lâge adulte mais déjà
c'est énorme he c'est une information
qu'on avait pas du tout on savait pas
combien de cocon il faisaient combien de
juvénil par cocon trouver le juvénil les
juvénils ils sont tous armaphrodites on
a eu des individus qu'on a récolté donc
au printemps 2023 qui ont été isolés à
leors arrivé au laboratoire et qui ont
fait des cocons après 6 à 8 mois en
isolation donc deux hypothèses soit ils
ont un organe qui leur permet de stocker
le sperme donc après fécondation mais 6
à 8 mois ça paraît une période
excessivement longue donc une autre
hypothèse ça pourrait être qu'ils sont
parténogénéti he qui vont faire des
clones de même et donc il peuvent se
reproduire tout seul il y a des choses à
dire hein il a du peu de matière quand
même donc ça c'est mon plus gros oh mon
dieu il est énorme ok mais moi il
m'a fait
peur ça c'est le plus gros spécimen que
moi j'ai jamais vu et ça c'est un
spécimen qu'on a depuis avril au labo
les vers pleins de cette espèce il font
maximum jusqu'à 20
cm mais bon donc voilà ils peuvent quand
même atteindre cette taille là et il y a
certaines espèces qui sont beaucoup plus
grandes donc notamment les les bipalium
qui sont à tête de marteau enfin qu'on
appelle vert plat à tête de marteau qui
peuvent faire jusqu'à 40 cm de de
longueur on a ce genre de de différence
de taille entre les juvéniles et un très
gros
adulte
ce qu'on fait ici ça va servir à déjà
augmenter les connaissances sur cette
espèce donc qui est pas très connu euh
ça peut éventuellement servir à mettre
en place de nouvelles législations
malheureusement on pense pas pouvoir se
débarrasser d'une espèce envahissante
une fois qu'elle est présente surtout
pas ce genre d'espèces là qui sont dans
le sol et très difficile à observer euh
par contre limiter les nouvelles
introductions euh limiter la répartition
entre jardins donc c'est veàut dire que
en France que les gens se enfin se
limitent et arrête de les répandre
partout ça peut être des choses qui
peuvent être mises en place hop là c'est
bon j'ai tout le monde JAAC parce que là
sil finissent par se répendre dans
laboratoire mais là du coup on en a
plein et notamment j'en ai un tout petit
je sais pas si vous pouvez le voir parce
que pour vous montrer à quel point ce
serait impossible de les voir dans des
plantes enau quand on parle de 6e
extinction de masse la plupart des gens
vont dire oui mais c'est bon il y a
toujours des girafes et des gnous oui
mais ceux-l on les voit parce qu'ils
sont énormes et en fait la biodiversité
qu'on perd le plus c'est la BI diversité
d'arthropodes donc les insectes et
d'invertébrés il y a certaines espèces
qui disparaissent sans avoir même jour
avoir été découvertes et les soles sont
très peu protégé d'ailleurs parce qu'on
protège les rivières on protège les mers
mais par contre le sol il y a très peu
de législation dessus à part le fait
d'être propriétaire d'un sol on a
quasiment rien et malheureusement c'est
c'est un peu dommage parce que c'est de
là que tout vient c'est comme ça qu'on
se nourrit c'est comme ça qu'on vit on
marche dessus on construit dessus donc
c'est très important de le
protéger
[Musique]
n'hésitez pas à nous dire ce que vous
avez pensé de ce verre en commentaire et
à liker la vidéo si elle vous a plu la
semaine prochaine on retrouvera un autre
épisode de la grande explication sur les
animaux ou l'environnement à
[Musique]
bientôt